JON ALPERT: Do you want
to introduce me, Robert?
-This my girl, Deliris.
-Hi.
JON: What are you guys gonna do?
ROBERT STEFFEY: Load up.
♪ (ROCK MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
Is it gonna be hard
to sell this stuff?
ROBERT: No, not at all.
Beats the minimum wage. (LAUGHS)
It's taking a chance out here.
♪ (DISTORTED "HAPPY BIRTHDAY"
PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER: You got a pocket
full of money. You want a taste?
JON: Is your mother
doing drugs every day?
(MUMBLING)
-(SNORTS)
-(LAUGHS)
ROBERT: These take
all the problems off the mind.
♪ (PENSIVE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
(CHUCKLES)
FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ:
Our mother and father got
divorced when we were young,
put me in a foster home.
If I would've stayed there
with those rich folks,
I wouldn't be here right now.
We're going to find out
the results of my HIV test.
My father works, 80 dollars
a week, for peanuts.
JON: You know what
your son does to make money?
ROBERT'S FATHER:
Yep. I don't like the idea.
(SIRENS WAIL)
ROBERT:
What'd I do to get locked up?
Dealing, doing drugs.
Free again.
You got any jobs? I need a job.
A lot of people went through
a lot of trouble to help me.
Now, why am I
gonna mess that up?
DELIRIS VASQUEZ: In and out
of jail, in and out of jail.
If you go back on drugs,
we can't live with you.
JON: How long you been
working the streets?
(TRUCK HONKS)
TRUCK DRIVER: I'm waitin'.
DELIRIS' CHILD:
If you love us so much, why
you not doing so good for us?
You never try.
I don't know
what I'm gonna do with my life.
DELIRIS: Stay strong, okay?
Just don't give up.
Don't give up.
DELIRIS' CHILD:
I know you can do it, ma.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪